VICTORY FOR RED "ANGLE."
WATCHING TODAY'S IMPEACHMENT
SPECTACLE AND LISTENING TO ALL
THE BLUSTER AND THE BLATHER, I
CAME AWAY WITH ONE OVERRIDING
THOUGHT.
AS AN EFFECTIVE AND PATHETIC THE
DEMOCRATS ARE AS LEGISLATORS,
THEY ARE EVEN WORSE ACTORS.
>> I SOLEMNLY AND SADLY OPEN THE
DEBATE ON THE IMPEACHMENT.
TODAY IS A SOLEMN DAY IN AMERICA
TODAY IS A SOLEMN DAY IN AMERIC.
A DAY THAT NONE OF US HOPE FOR.
>> IT IS WITH A SOLEMN SENSE OF
DUTY THAT I RISE TODAY TO
SUPPORT IMPEACHMENT.
>> A SAD DAY FOR AMERICA.
>> I AM NOT GLEEFUL FOR TODAY.
>> Laura: NO, THEY ARE NOT
GLEEFUL BUT THEY ARE NOT SOLEMN
OR PRAYERFUL EITHER.
BY THE WAY, THEY WERE REPORTEDLY
TAKING SELFIES ON THE HOUSE
FLOOR TONIGHT.
FOR A FEW MONTHS, THOUGH, THEY
WERE ECSTATIC WHEN THEY THOUGHT
A WHISTLEBLOWER WAS GOING TO
DELIVER A VICTORY NEXT NOVEMBER.
A VICTORY THEY KNEW WAS GOING TO
BE DIFFICULT AMIDST A GROWING
ECONOMY.
THEY NEEDED SOMETHING TO HELP
THEM BUT THEN THE IMPEACHMENT
POLES STARTED TO TURN.
NOT ONE OR TWO BUT SEVERAL
SHOWING AMERICANS AREN'T BUYING
THEIR EVIDENCE FREE HYPERBOLE ON
UKRAINE.
AFTER COUNTLESS HOURS, SO
TEDIOUS, THESE SPEECHES, PANELS
OF LIBERAL ACADEMICS AND HEARSAY
WITNESSES AND BITTER FOREIGN
SERVICE OFFICERS, FEWER
AMERICANS, NOT MORE, BELIEVE
THAT DONALD TRUMP COMMITTED AN
IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE.
AMERICANS ARE PRETTY SMART,
AREN'T THEY?
THEY CAN SPOT A SHAM WHEN THEY
SEE ONE.
THE SAME DEMOCRATS WHO
VEHEMENTLY OPPOSED IMPEACHING
CLINTON IN THE 1990s BECAUSE
THE CRIMES WEREN'T SERIOUS
ENOUGH.
THEY NOW WANT TO TRUMP REMOVED
FROM OFFICE FOR COMMITTING NO
CRIME AT ALL.
REPEATING A LIE OVER AND OVER
AGAIN, SCHIFF THOUGHT, WOULD BE
ENOUGH TO WIN OVER AMERICA.
THAT IS HOW LITTLE HE THINKS OF
YOUR INTELLIGENCE.
THERE WAS A BLIZZARD OF LIES
FLYING AROUND THE HOUSE CHAMBER
TODAY, SO WE ARE GOING TO FOCUS
TONIGHT AND JUST THE IMPORTANT
ONES.
LINE NUMBER ONE, THE FACTS ARE
SETTLED.
>> THE UNCONTESTED EVIDENCE
SHOWS DONALD TRUMP VIOLATED HIS
OATH OF OFFICE OF OFFICE.
>> THE FACTS ARE
BLACK-AND-WHITE.
>> THE EVIDENCE IS UNDISPUTED.
>> NOT A SINGLE FACT IN THIS
CASE IS SERIOUSLY IN DISPUTE.
>> Laura: THIS IS LUDICROUS ON
ITS FACE.
JIM JORDAN TOLD THE STORY WELL
EARLIER THIS EVENING.
>> DEMOCRATS FORGOT TWO KEY
THINGS.
FORGOT ABOUT THE FACTS AND THEY
FORGOT ABOUT FAIRNESS.
NO QUID PRO QUO.
TWO GUYS ON THE CALL WHO
REPEATEDLY SAID THERE WAS NO
PRESSURE.
MOST IMPORTANT, UKRAINE TOOK NO
ACTION, NO ANNOUNCEMENT OF
INVESTIGATION TO GET THE AID
RELEASED BY DEMOCRATS DON'T
CARE.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT THE FACTS
AND THEY SURE DON'T CARE ABOUT
THE PROCESS.
>> Laura: IN OTHER WORDS, MARK
SMALL WELL IS ON WELL IF HE
THINKS THE EVIDENCE IS UNDISPUTE
THINKS THE EVIDENCE IS UNDISPUT.
LIE NUMBER TWO, THIS HAS BEEN AN
OPEN, ABOVEBOARD, AND TOTALLY
FAIR PROCESS.
>> MEMBERS OF BOTH PARTIES HAVE
BEEN INVOLVED IN EVERY STAGE.
>> OVER 100 MEMBERS WERE ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE.
>> THE PRESIDENT WAS GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY BEFORE
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE TO SEND
THE COUNCIL TO TEST WITNESSES.
HE DECLINED TO DO SO.
>> Laura: ANY LAWYER WHO
WOULD'VE ADVISED TRUMP TO APPEAR
BEFORE SCHIFF SHOULD BE
DISBARRED.
AGAIN, JORDAN NAILED IT.
>> NO REPUBLICAN WITNESSES
DURING THE DEPOSITIONS,
REPUBLICANS WERE PREVENTED
FROM GETTING ALL THEIR QUESTIONS
ANSWERED.
BUT DEMOCRATS GOT EVERY UP THERE
QUESTIONS.
AND OF COURSE THE ANONYMOUS
WHISTLEBLOWER WITH NO FIRSTHAND
EVIDENCE, BIAS AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT, THE GUY WHO STARTED
IT ALL.
>> Laura: I ALMOST DIDN'T
RECOGNIZE HIM BECAUSE HE GOT THE
JACKET ON.
LIE NUMBER THREE, TRUMP USED
UKRAINIAN AID FOR POLITICAL
LEVERAGE.
>> HE LEVERAGED CRITICALLY
NEEDED, CONGRESSIONALLY APPROVED
MILITARY AID TO UKRAINE.
>> IN ORDER TO COERCE A
FRAUDULENT INVESTIGATION INTO A
POTENTIAL POLITICAL OPPONENT.
>> MILITARY AID USED TO FIGHT AS
LEVERAGE, SOLELY TO BENEFIT HIS
OWN POLITICAL CAMPAIGN.
GEORGE WASHINGTON WOULD BE
ASTONISHED.
>> Laura: GEORGE WASHINGTON?
DEMOCRATS ARE NOW SUDDENLY
CLAIRVOYANCE.
HERE ARE THE FACTS.
UKRAINIAN'S MILITARY AIDE WAS
DELAYED A MERE 55 DAYS IN
REASONABLE BOUNDS.
IT WAS RELEASED WITHIN THE
TIME FRAME ESTABLISHED BY
CONGRESS.
UKRAINE DIDN'T HAVE TO ANNOUNCE
INVESTIGATIONS INTO THE BIDENS
WITH THE 2016 ELECTION OR TAKE
ANY OTHER ACTION.
IT'S RIDICULOUS.
LIE NUMBER FOUR, TRUMP ACTIVELY
FOUGHT FOR AN ELECTION MEDDLING.
>> THE PRESIDENT ACTIVELY SOUGHT
FOR AN ELECTION INTERFERENCE TO
BENEFIT HIMSELF.
>> THE INTEGRITY OF THE 2020
ELECTION REMAINS AT RISK.
>> DONALD TRUMP SACRIFICED OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY IN AN EFFORT
TO CHEAT IN THE NEXT ELECTION.
>> Laura: IF YOU THINK OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY IS INTIMATELY
CONNECTED WITH UKRAINE, THEN
WE'VE GOT TO GO BACK TO SCHOOL,
OKAY?
IT'S RIDICULOUS.
WE HAVE THE TRANSCRIPT OF
TRUMP'S CALL WITH ZELENSKY.
HE NEVER ONCE MENTIONS THE 2020
ELECTION, THEN THERE IS THE
SMALL MATTER OF THAT STUMBLING,
BUMBLING JOE BIDEN.
THE FACT THAT HE HASN'T WON'S
PARTY'S NOMINATION YET.
HE ISN'T TRUMP'S ULTIMATE RIVAL.
THE BIDENS, LIKE THE CLINTONS,
BROUGHT THIS PROBLEM ON
THEMSELVES BY IGNORING OBVIOUS
CONFLICTS OF INTEREST.
THE REASON, HUNTER, AND
ACCEPTING LARGE SUMS OF MONEY
WHEN THEY SHOULDN'T HAVE.
SO I'M GLAD THE PRESIDENT WANTS
ANSWERS ABOUT ALL OF THAT.
JOE BIDEN DOESN'T GET A FREE
PASS FROM SCRUTINY BECAUSE HE IS
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT, THAT IS
ABSURD.
LIE NUMBER FIVE, NO ONE IS ABOVE
THE LAW.
>> I KNOW THE PRESIDENT SAID
THAT HE COULD GET AWAY WITH
ANYTHING HE WANTS TO.
NO, HE CANNOT BECAUSE NO ONE IS
ABOVE THE LAW.
>> IF YOU LIVE ON
1600 PENNSYLVANIA AVENUE, YOU
ARE NOT ABOVE THE LAW.
>> Laura: AT LEAST HE KNOWS
THE ADDRESS OF THE WHITE HOUSE.
WAIT A SECOND, DEMOCRATS DON'T
BELIEVE THAT FOR A SECOND.
BY THEIR OWN CONDUCT AND POLICY.
FROM THE WAY THEY SHIELDED THE
CLINTONS TO THE WAY THEY
CURRENTLY SHIELD THE BIDENS.
THEY DON'T EVEN WANT THOSE
QUESTIONS ASKED.
AND OF COURSE, THE WAY THEY CROP
UP AND CODDLE ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
WHO ARE SO FAR OUT OF THE
SHADOWS AT THIS POINT THAT THEY
LINED UP A BLOCK BY BLOCK BY
BLOCK TO WAIT FOR DRIVERS
LICENSES IN NEW YORK THIS WEEK.
LINE NUMBER SIX, TRUMP IS
OBSTRUCTING CONGRESS.
>> HE TRIED TO COVER UP HIS
SCANDALOUS BEHAVIOR AND HE
OBSTRUCTED THE INVESTIGATION.
>> HE OBSTRUCTED CONGRESS EVERY
STEP OF THE WAY IN AN EFFORT TO
COVER IT ALL UP.
>> HE HAS BLOCKED NUMEROUS
WITNESSES FROM TESTIFYING ABOUT
HIS ACTIONS.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP'S ACTIONS ARE
EVEN WORSE THAN NIXON'S.
>> Laura: TALK ABOUT A ZERO
CREDIBILITY.
NEW YORK MUST BE SO PROUD.
DEMOCRATS WANT YOU TO BELIEVE
THAT THE PRESIDENT CHALLENGING
SUBPOENAS IN COURT, OR ASSERTING
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE IS AN
IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE.
GUESS WHAT, AS ALAN DERSHOWITZ
HAS SAID SO MANY TIMES ON THIS
SHOW, THAT WOULD EVISCERATE
EXECUTIVE AUTHORITY.
IF DEMOCRATS WANTED TO SHOW
OBSTRUCTION, THEY NEEDED TO FILE
AN EMERGENCY PETITION IN COURT.
SO WHY DIDN'T THEY?